todavía fuera de control es el estado de
cerca de 30 incendios en la región de
Alberta Canadá 98 focos que han afectado
la zona siguen activos Aunque la
temperatura más fresca y algo de lluvia
ayudaron a los bomberos la situación aún
preocupa las autoridades más de 390.000
hectáreas han quedado quemadas en lo que
va del año
en este momento hay 15 órdenes de
evacuación vigentes con más de 29,000
personas evacuadas de manera segura de
sus hogares Y 10.000 evacuados se han
registrado en 11 centros de recepción
unos 700 bomberos intentan contener las
llamas Alberta ha solicitado otros 1000
de otras provincias también se hizo un
llamado a voluntarios que tengan
habilidades para que ayuden en la causa
el gobierno anunció que brindará ayudas
económicas a los damnificados no hay
duda de que este es un momento difícil
decenas de miles de personas se han
visto obligadas a abandonar sus hogares
Y trabajos están dejando atrás todo lo
que poseen preguntándose si perderán
todo por lo que han trabajado los
incendios llevaron al gobierno local a
declarar el estado de emergencia en
Alberta el sábado Canadá es el cuarto
productor mundial de crudo 80% del cual
se extrae de aquí pero las empresas del
sector energético debieron dejar de
enviar unos 280,000 barriles más del 3%
de la producción total canadiense las
exportaciones de gas natural hacia
Estados Unidos cayeron a unos 189.000
litros por día la cifra más baja desde
abril de 2021